nine victims remain hospitalized for in
critical condition following the
deadliest terror attack in New York City
since 9/11 eight killed and a dozen
injured by a jihadi who mowed them down
with a truck and then shouted Allahu
Akbar
we have more information today about the
suspect his motive and how he came to
America the immigrant from Uzbekistan
was allowed into the country in 2010 on
a diversity visa president trunk now
vowing to end the lottery program and
today starting the process of
terminating the diversity lottery
program diversity lottery sounds nice
it's not nice it's not good so we want
to immediately work with Congress on the
diversity lottery program on terminating
it getting rid of it we want a
merit-based program where people come
into our country based on merit worn out
from Catherine Herridge our chief
intelligent correspondent in Washington
Catherine well thanks Dan this afternoon
homeland security officials confirmed to
Fox News that the suspect was admitted
under a valid visa for the program in
March of 2010 and that the program does
require an interview of the State
Department and additional screening as
you just mentioned President Trump said
he is in the process of terminating the
program because he favors a merit-based
approach not a program like the lottery
that traditionally tilts in favor of
countries with historically low rates of
immigration we learned today the suspect
was among the maximum fifty thousand
people allowed into the US every year
under the State Department program and
about 24,000 people have entered the
u.s. from the country of us-pakistan
since 2005 and that's where the suspect
was born also today two sources telling
Fox News and that the suspect had
connections to individuals who were
already known to law enforcement at that
New York City briefing earlier today the
Deputy Commissioner for counterterrorism
explained the suspect was running with a
very suspicious crowd meantime new
photos obtained by Fox News give you a
better sense of new jersey's Omar mosque
and the focus of multiple leads after
9/11 the suspects brick apartment
building is virtually on its
or step you see it right there with the
mosque the white building in the
distance a former federal investigator
with pent bomb that's the codename for
the 911 file so the area is about four
to five blocks from 9/11 hijacker and
ringleader Mohammed Atta's apartment as
well as where the muscle hijackers were
located and they finalized the 2001 plot
so this area remains really very much a
nest as it was described to us or an
enclave for radical teachings Dana all
right Catherine thank you so much the
president has directed Homeland Security
to ramp up extreme vetting of foreigners
in the wake of the attacks we have to
get much tougher we have to get much
smarter and we have to get much less
politically correct
we're so politically correct that we're
afraid to do anything and that's not
only our country that's other countries
too that are having very similar
problems and we have to get tough we
have to get smart we have to do what's
right to protect our citizens
Greg it's interesting that he brings
that up today because Pew Research poll
had a poll out today that said 71% of
Americans are concerned about how
politically correct America has become
well you know we talked about political
opportunism but the real political
opportunism after terrorism is the
application of Islamophobia
if anybody expresses concern over
radical Islam you get in trouble and
there's this conflict now where you have
today you have the mayor and the
governor saying there are eight million
people in New York City there's a
million pair of eyes if you say so if
you see something say something
but you can't say something in this
current climate because you will lose
your job if this guy was already on our
radar he was interviewed by the feds in
2015 because he had links online to
certain kinds of bad groups but why
didn't they go after him maybe they were
scared that they were gonna lose their
job they're gonna lose their job and
this is how everybody feels I'm tired of
this hypocrisy where they say if you see
something say something because they
really don't want you to do anything
because a moment you do something you
are you are labeled Islamophobic you're
labeled a bigot so if you look at what
them if you look at what Trump does
the media does this the leaders do it
about Islamophobia he doesn't he's the
closest to the ground of any president
I've ever seen talking about the actual
sincere fears of the average citizen you
know there are things that I know I'm
not gonna like his tax plan I don't
understand his 401k stuff it's gonna
drive me crazy but his response and this
is the most important thing his response
to the presence of terror is so much
more important to the reaction after
terror when you see Cuomo and you see
mayor de Blasio and everybody else
saying how strong New York is and how
we're gonna we're gonna have that parade
that's a who cares it's about you
response before the attack your
willingness to admit that there is the
presence of terror before terror strikes
it's no good afterwards to give sympathy
after it's happened it doesn't matter
what matters is having the guts to say
it's here how do we get rid of it and
then you get targeted for Islamophobia
so it takes guts to say what he is
saying to talk about the diversity visa
is important diversity untethered to
merit is of no value and remember I was
just a few years ago that I think was
The Associated Press went after the NYPD
right for monitoring these mosques
including that one that Catherine
Harridge was just playing that's example
did all Hasan they knew about him nobody
said anything at Fort Hood President
Trump also today one pointed out
immediately early this morning that
Chuck Schumer the senator from New York
had supported diversity visas he didn't
point out that Chuck Schumer had also
voted to change that program even though
that bill didn't get to the President's
desk under President Obama listen to
some of the Democrats responding to
Trump look the last thing the president
or anyone else should do is politicize
this tragedy I don't think this is the
time to get political there's no doubt
that we have to be smarter and have more
intelligence but there's also no doubt
that this is not the time to play
politics this is not the time to foment
hate all president Trump does
is take advantage horrible advantage of
a tragedy and try to politicize and
divide the American people long for
leadership not divisive nough supporting
not name-calling this is a tragedy
your thoughts one well I don't think
there's any question from Chuck
Schumer's point of view this is the
tragedy this is his home state this is
New York City I think where I would
differ from Greg is I think that when
you say let's go forward with the
Halloween parade let's continue to live
our lives or in the language of
President Bush you know let's not let
the terrorists win through intimidation
I think that's a very important message
now when you're talking about something
like prevention I don't think is any
question that our country has taken
logical steps to what we call hardened
targets right make it more difficult to
go through the airport to get a visa
it's very dude president crumbs talking
about extreme vetting it takes two years
if you're a Syrian refugee we have
extreme measures rating plate I want to
know what he's gonna do to make it more
extreme but I think there's a box of I
only citizens to say something and then
you punish them I don't think so at all
in fact I think the contrary is the case
I think you have people including me who
said something say but but guess what
when you say something these days I
think there are lots of people like Greg
who would say thank God somebody stood
up and said I don't know anything and I
think the police the police by the way
are very appreciative of informants and
they had many informants in these very
mosques that they have been surveilling
as another example of the fact that it's
not like we're a bunch of oaths and
they've never taken any steps to protect
ourselves we have people who are
surveilling the mosque and then the
question becomes a much more difficult
question for you as a libertarian about
privacy and rights of you know private
work for the American Constitution here
is above freedom but it is true that
when people say something to authorities
they are automatically presumed to be
Islamophobic we're not even allowed to
talk about what catherine herridge
discussed as a nest of jihadists because
that would be going after a Muslim
American community of immigrants and
therefore you are bigoted and
want more people to come into the
country the left is making two different
arguments here the first is that you
have to choose between proper vetting
more vetting of people foreigners coming
into the country or nothing at all
because you would be bigoted to do so
and you're going after minorities as a
result the second thing they're saying
is well it's it's the Athan the American
people in the country to be more
welcoming to particularly Islamic
immigrants who come to this country
because if you aren't then they're not
going to assimilate and therefore they
may go into terror and turn to terror as
if that is a justification for something
like this happening we don't owe them
anything they owe America a lot Jason
before I go to you and just a note that
the US Attorney of New York is going to
hold a press conference later this hour
they will be announcing terrorism
charges against the suspect so we'll
bring that to you live it will be later
in this hour so don't don't miss that
Jason yeah but I think Craig is
absolutely right what does it mean to
actually be on a watch list because
nobody's really actually watching up if
you think that they're actually watching
them what they're doing where they're
surfing the internet they're not doing
anything like 14 NYPD or intelligence
officials and per one guy that they're
watching so we have a resource problem
possibly well but Homeland Security
funding has actually gone up despite
what that number was just cut in the
budget that the Republicans just passed
absolutely wrong because what happened
was the appropriations went up they
actually went from 47 point eight
billion to 49 point three billion and
the appropriation for 2018 is 51 point 1
billion he wordsmith it he tried to say
well the proposed budget but what was
actually appropriated went up so he
knows what he won he must he was getting
his word out there but he didn't have
much policy to stand on the thing that
bothers me is if you go back to the
Boston bombing and this is part of what
Greg's point is we didn't do anything
now I introduced a bill to actually do
some things with asylum seekers who
violate this and actually go back to
their country of origin back and forth
this country still today does not have
an entry/exit program I can go down and
buy a sandwich at my gun
all foes place and get a turkey sandwich
and the tenth time I do it I get a free
one because they know if I come and gone
to their shop if you go and believe this
country and come back we don't know this
person today I promise you nobody can
definitively tell you if he actually
left the country yeah this guy came here
and he was vetted as part of the program
and apparently no alarm bells went off
right so they did though no they did all
the place not at all and so here's the
thing
he was led to this horrible act by
something that happened while he was in
the United States and this is what we
really need to talk about what he was
because of association with those other
folks now we're we're singing out in a
Moscow screeching monocle ideology
hanging out my point to you is I think
that this took place online the
conversion to radical Islam that sees
online and unless we get away from what
I think is a distraction and one that's
I think politically advantageous to
President Trump to talk about we need to
vet more we need to stop none of the
people on his muslim banlist none of
them including this invent would have
been stopped by his muslim well you said
that there weren't any red flags at all
there are the mosques that you went to
there was not you think that this has
all happened online which which most of
this whole thing about trucks look at
nice right look at what happened in
Times Square five months ago they're
using vehicles as weapons right you
specifically said when he came here
something happened he was living in
America they can do this so if you look
at everything around him the people he
was hanging out with which by the way he
has friends one of which the FBI
believes as a terrorist who is missing
now in the United States he was going to
a mosque that was under FBI surveillance
and this was happening online which
though you clearly did not catch he was
because you have additional information
the FBI now is saying that they are
seeking information on a second person
they believe was involved in this attack
and okay that flies in the face we keep
talking about online recruit
which is true but we also have to admit
the fact that they have friends and that
they have relatives and we've had two
examples the Boston bombing were
brothers and in San Bernardino it was a
husband and wife so we have to
understand that this is a family thing
it's a tribal it's a tribal thing it's
it's it's fantasy it's an ideology so it
infects a lot of different people my
last point is you know it's not it is a
coincidence that this happened on
Halloween but there's a metaphor there
that has been used before that when your
kids come home with a bag of candy the
parents bet it they go through it they
make sure nothing Bad's in there because
they took something outside and they
brought it inside and the parents go
through it and they look through it and
that's not absurd to do that is not
absurd it's what a parent does applying
that logic right now in a changing world
when the outside is coming in with a
pernicious idot ideology the razor blade
in the Apple is radical Islam you have
every right to vet but one more thing
because they keep telling me it's some
more information so within this hour the
US Attorney will have a press conference
they will announce charges against the
suspect sources are saying that the
suspect does not show remorse for the
attack that he is being cooperative
so that possibly could be the reason the
FBI is seeking information about a
second person so we're gonna have all of
that for you in this hour he may have
acted alone but all indications are the
New York City terror suspect was
inspired by Isis so how do we fight this
new front in the war on terror we'll be
right back